are you interested in our ideas yes I
see not because you're always presenting
me quotes from people who obviously do
not like the party instead you should
ask me questions about how you want to
change European politics you can answer
questions because that's what a free
press does oh yes you unless you unless
you want to give me a script and invite
me too you don't put it the way it was
and I'm surprised about that because
again we did not raise this topic but I
mean if you want to reduce safety to
that sort of question we can go on for
at least now I talk about that but we
not get an idea about AF D so if our aim
is to get into a lot at one point and
again I think we should differentiate
and a question sorry you didn't do that
oh I I did I tried to get a straight
answer out of you but I didn't manage it
oh yeah you did okay you talked about
the press the hubris of the state media
with their possibly corrupt connections
you don't think much of the media do
well we see in Germany we are we've seen
it for a long time said that we don't
have neutral reporting's in many cases
that comments and reports are mixed up
in I think in a way that do you have
evidence of corrupt reaction it gets
hard for the readers and for the viewers
to see where the neutral report is and
were the personal view of the
commentators and that shouldn't happen
especially not in public me is that our
finance basically about taxes do you
have evidence of corrupt connections
media because you won't be interested in
hearing which quote you're just
presenting me because I can't
remember ever having said if you want
corrupt I said I have sensibly I have
said many times that we don't have
neutral media and yes I think that's
true